four square but this is the most natural
move kick away white's best piece that
white piece is just holding everything
together blocking the d line so why not
just remove it okay force it back so
white knight has to move
dude is slapping his own head there he's
not happy at all seconds left three
okay he goes back
from uh but that's an admission of
defeat he's basically just lost two
moves there duder he's so devastated now
black has
black sport for choice
move that i would really love to play is
actually to move my knight from the c5
square and put it on a4 and just keep
upping the pressure on that b2 pawn
because if you try to push that pawn
forward ah my knight's going to come to
c3 and it's going to be a deadly check
all you need to do is add one more piece
to the attack black's queen and black's
porn are fantastic doing a great job ae2
that white pawn is dropping you just
simply can't block that diagonal unless
you give up a knight
dude has done that desperation now yeah
with seven seconds left on the clock for
do that yeah
i mean it was that move all you resign
so you might as well flick in a
confusing move for the opponent but then
i can simply be captured okay
okay well this is uh a little bit tricky
to handle after all the black king
is unprotected
um i think fortunately for magnus the
black queen can bring itself across and
block any potential checks
um
the black king looks open but there's no
way for the knight to jump towards the
black king because the black rook on the
d-line cuts off any potential entry
squares for the white knight and four
seconds for duda three seconds and
there's a choice between giving a check
or resigning and he chooses to resign
wow look at magnus racing his eyebrows
maybe getting a little bit lucky there
but fantastic play by the world champion
and what a result a win in the first
game with the black pieces